bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono toni j
ed oggi siamo in un nuovo blog che c'è
va bene ragazzi non sarebbe uno stato
qualcosa di strano no vorrei iniziare
come in ogni blog con la parte della
settimana evitando di guardare sempre
didietro elaborate da settimana questa
settimana è stata vinta da sofia chi ha
fatto questo disegno è un disegno
io comunque vorrei fare una precisazione
sono sicuro che nel 2500 ragazzi
studieranno nei libri di arte e di b a
te quando fanno vedere gli artisti di
500 anni prima quindi del 2014 più o
meno io sono convinto che ci saranno
delle pagine scritte su quei cazzo di
libri con su scritto le sue prime opere
furono delle fan art per farmi j sono
convinto di sta cosa perché come cazzo
può essere un disegno questo non è
possibile quindi ragazzi direi di
passare dalle news ogni cielo di fare
così non lo so perché probabilmente
imparerò a volare dopo sto blog sarà la
prima cosa oggi sono tornato a casa mi
sono seduto aperto steam
ed è un sito 8 del dl e sketch che
sarebbe il seguito di otto dead è dio
mio non vedo fottutamente l'ora di
provarlo perché quel gioco è è fuori di
testa seconda news
among the slip che veramente è un indica
avevo fatto mesi e mesi fa comunque era
ancora in alpha e sta per uscire ragazza
è una cosa incredibile non vedo l'ora
quindi andrò a fare anche quello e
aspetta soltanto che esca in verbis
virtus che me lo state chiedendo in un
miliardo di persone da quando l'ho fatto
ma è ancora in alto ancora lo stanno
facendo quindi non ancora uscito ma
quando uscira 7 tranquilli che faccio
anche quello smettete di scatenare la
terza guerra mondiale con i ragazzi
della settimana ho visto che avete
apprezzato tantissimo aver grau che non
ho ancora capito come cazzo si pronuncia
anche quelli del gioco sui conigli che
si menano è veramente ragazzi quella
roba e assurda mi avete chiesto tutti di
farci una serie è probabilmente ce l'ha
adesso sto guardando se parla di temi se
volete se volete ok questo era
importante vdv temi effettivamente se
volete che faccia la serie la farò di
sicuro ragazzi perché
e un gioco che mi fa impazzire poi
l'hanno anche aggiornato quindi meglio
ancora ragazzi come ultima news volevo
dirvi una cosa che mi state chiedendo
chi momenti tantissimi da quando ho
fatto le interviste in radio che era
tipo tre settimane fa na roba del genere
avevo preannunciato che avrei fatto a
febbraio il 15 febbraio resto però credo
all'evento anche su facebook così almeno
chi partecipa può mettere gli partecipa
così almeno ci organizziamo tutti quanti
farò un un raduno vero e proprio ad
ascoli perché è da un anno che mi state
fracassando le balle questa cosa mi
avete chiesto di fare i raduni ovunque
variamente emerge a roma napoli a milano
a palermo su marte su venere ring i
ragazzi vi farò un po ovunque quindi non
preoccupatevi comunque ragazzi il primo
raduno che farò lo farò ad ascoli e sarà
il 15 di febbraio con che a breve creare
un evento su facebook mettendo la data
al giorno l'ora l'indirizzo a che ora
vado a cagare quindi ci organizziamo
bene tutti quindi almeno sappiamo e
quindi ragazzi detto questo direi che
possiamo passare allo scatto dei pacchi
che ammettetelo che lo state guardando
da mezz'ora ragazzi io quando quando
apro le scatole in genere esagero nel
senso che dico madonna su scatola enorme
in effetti sono abbastanza grosse ma
cazzo credetemi se vi dico che questa
[ __ ] scatola e più grossa di me
beh comunque ragazzi direi di aprirlo
per ultimo il mammut perché magari dato
è rimasto lì per qualche migliaio di
anni quindi lei che ci può stare
altri cinque minuti e direi di aprire
prima questi tre che sono comunque
grandi anche se quel coso lì è
imparagonabile comunque volevo aprire
questo come prima ragazzi perché mi
piace un casino la scritta ragazzi cioè
la gara la scatola c'è un profumo
impressionante a perfetto per questo
questo mi mancava ancora la collezione
il pupazzo dello sla è no vabbè questa
una figata là fuori che i ragazzi
abbiamo abbiamo abbiamo un ovetto di
peppa pig che forse credo sia meglio
dire avevamo un ovetto di beffa big e
come ultimo c'è una fan art spettacolare
ragazzi perché è bellissima la pizza di
the crush è veramente grazie infinite
per questo pacco era splendido
soprattutto l'odore this lander me che
l'ho anche ragazzi vi giuro che lui è il
pupazzo più figo che abbia mai ricevuto
questo è un dato di fatto che comunque
ragazzi vieni passare al prossimo perché
è una subito hanno pronti a farli tutti
così i pacchi madonna che mi avreste
risparmiato tanto di quel tempo sia
questa cosa mi sta simpatico poi abbiate
pazienti cos'è che ragazzi qualcuno mi
aiuti a capire che cos'è sto coso perché
non non ancora e morbide filo in
compenso il pacco era semplice d'aprile
ma le cose dentro no ci ho messo quattro
ore e mezza ma non importa se ne avete
mi avete inviato una scatola in tv fa
visse quick da avevo detto nè scritto
all'inizio perfetto allora allora è
tutta un'altra storia tra l'altro sono
sempre più dell idea che dovrei scrivere
vietato mettere i giornali nei fatti
perché sta diventando una cosa
insostenibile se poi sono proporzionati
giornali in base alla grandezza dei
piccoli dentro c'è la foresta amazzonica
ho trovato ragazzi di questo scrigno
fantastico questa cosa qui non può paura
ad aprire sinceramente c'è a always a
perfetto c'è la pagina di flander mi
mancava questa deprimenti allo slider me
la pagina adesso seguendo il suo si
trova la torcia siamo praticamente a
posto regala una fararte bellissima poi
c'è la mia mezza foto con scritto keep
calm and love fa vj questa questa questa
mela appendo direttamente sulla porta di
camera mia perché alzo al suo stile
quindi ragazzi adesso direi che ci siamo
tenetevi forte ma in fondo non è che ci
avessi conta st voglia di aprirla con la
scatola enorme alla fine era una cosa
era una cosa che desideravo fare da
troppo tempo con aprire un poche norme
prima cosa prendere il coltello
anzi prendere un grande coltello qualche
dato e ripetutamente il pacco fino allo
sfinimento più cattiveria e dopo di che
provate ad aprirlo con la forza bruta
più forza bruta cazzo ragazzi voi non
potete capire che cosa cazzo c'era lì
dentro
voi capite che quando uno pensa di
essere arrivato al limite e poi ti
arriva a questo ma che cazzo ciao
ragazzi io credo di essere in possesso
della nutella più grossa del mondo
ragazzi cercate di capire questa è una è
una nutella normale col mio nome tra
l'altro ed è normale questa questa è una
delle mute linee piccole di quella che è
che mi avete regalato negli altri blog
e poi c'è questo tema che siccome ho
paura di aprire sta cosa e prendere il
diabete solo a guardarla va bene se
lasciamo chiuso non c'è problema
vi ringrazio per avermi dato una modella
così enorme perché è giusto aver mi
mancava la mattina metterla sul pane
quindi a dimenticavo se qualcuno per
caso del pal e delle dimensioni di un
camion io giorgio la nutella ogni siamo
a posto ai ragazzi purtroppo perché un
casino di cosa da fare non riesco a fare
al fare risponde però voglio dirvi che
il prossimo blog cercherò di rispondere
a delle domande che mi chiedete da
tantissimo tempo che non ho mai risposto
sono domande serie queste che volevo
assolutamente di dare una risposta
perché me lo chiedete da quando ho
aperto il canale praticamente e sono del
tipo come mai ti chiami fa vj come mai
ci va beh insomma delle domande su con
cosa registico però sono domande serie
alla quale voglio dare delle risposte
veramente serie e non avendo tempo di
farli questo blog perché devo fare un
casino di cose lo farò nel prossimo
abbia sicuro che lo faccio i ragazzi se
non mi dispiace io vado a cercare un
mega apriscatole per aprire sta roba
[Musica]
e noi ci rivediamo un prossimo video
dalla ragazze